hey I'm Carlos Bustamante with ET Canada
in Toronto by the way I heard you yeah
awesome baby where we shot it it's your
second or third home hey it is man how
is it there is it getting cold not yet
man it's beautiful here today perfect
so I gotta say guys I knew going into
this when I was watching it that you
know I was gonna have a good time for
sure but what I was not ready for was
like how many heartstrings you guys
reached in and just grabbed and pulled
like I literally had the cliche
singletier thing going on I was like
what like what's going on here Jason
when you were in the midst of filming
emotional scenes with Marlo do you get
that feeling as well like I know you
know you're gonna have it when you watch
it but when you're in the middle of it
are you feeling that yeah I'm a sucker I
cry a lot so
um I try not to show it but yeah there's
definitely a lot of emotional moments
and that's what helps you kind of get
there too so
I mean I think having kids it kind of
keeps you really vulnerable and open to
all those things so
um
yeah I that's what I loved about it too
when I read it I was crying so that was
not too many scripts that I read that I
get a plan that I get to cry and so I
was in
yeah so Marlo we know that when people
are watching it they've got to have a
box of tissues by their side for sure
what else do you suggest they keep with
them should they keep like their
favorite stuffed toy for emotional
support like what else should people be
uh having with them on their watches
movie
I'd say
grab a snack and a drink
um definitely the box of tissues I like
the stuffed animal one yeah I'd say I'd
say hold a stuffed animal with you or
something you care about whether it be a
person or a stuffed animal
um
yeah I'd say that's that's probably my
go-to what I
have when I watch a movie is a snack and
a drink
yeah and upset now I I was looking at
like what are the most popular dreams
that people have had and one that stuck
out to me that I've had a lot is that
dream where like you go back to school
and you're just not prepared for
whatever it is that you're doing on that
day is there a dream that you guys have
like constantly that either throws you
or you know conversely that you actually
love to be in and you don't want to wake
up from Jason what do you think I'm
pretty bad dreamer that's why I love
doing this movie I'm so big that when I
lay down I go into a coma and then I
just wake up and I remember nothing so I
kind of live my dreams and uh I do a lot
of maybe daydreaming you catch me going
like this and wandering off and having
little Daydreams but loving where I'm at
so yeah Marlo's way better at her dream
so aren't you Marlo
I'd say my dreams are pretty whack
um and I feel like I could write a book
about most of my dreams because they're
really weird but I feel like if I gave
them to like a writer
then we could turn it into like a great
movie
um I'd say yeah I have a lot of dreams
that felt so real that when I woke up I
was like dang it I want to go back now
because I felt like everything was going
really good but it was also really
realistic so that way when I woke up I
was like okay now I gotta go back to
living my normal life it sounds to me
like the secret to writing the sequel
for this movie is just you writing down
what you dreamed that night boom boom I
think
we could write Slumberland 2 right here
right now oh my gosh you should do it
100 percent
now uh Jason with Henry Cavill back in
the tights as Superman I gotta say man
it looks like things are open for the
for the JL to come back together maybe
take on Black Adam what are your
thoughts I think with Peter Safran and
uh Mr Gunn at the helm now of DC
um very excited about that there's a lot
of there's a lot of cool things going to
be coming up and uh one of my dreams
come true will be happening under their
watch so
stay tuned
I love that stand with the dream theme
okay thank you so much for the time such
a great time chatting with you all of
that